hey advances segment where I take a less
structured and humorous approach to look
at any topic that crosses my mind
relating to the subject of anime and
manga it contains my raw buys the pin
and it's for the purpose of creating the
bait and all discussion so shouldn't be
taken too seriously got that great I
shut up a listen so a recent topic
that's been red-hot in the anime
community recently is the topic of anime
on television and it's certainly a topic
that I thought about a lot personally
what sparked this discussion was of
course Adult Swim's brief revival of the
Toonami TV block a few weeks ago on
April Fool's Day now for any of you who
have no idea what tsunami is or what the
recent revival was all about well here's
a brief rundown for any of my younger
viewers who have no memory of this
tsunami was an action oriented
programming block on the channel Cartoon
Network that ran for over eleven years
before being cancelled on the 20 of
September 2008 the block brands some
American cartoons but more notably it
was a TV home to a number of different
anime many of which are now considered
as called classics in the Western anime
community Dragon Ball Z Hyuk Shogun de
Wing outlaw star Tenchi Muyo and a fair
few others last for - just a few weeks
going on April 1st 2012 I'll swim sights
to bring back the tsunami block for just
one nights only as an April Fool's joke
re-airing many of the aforementioned
shows along with new promos and bumpers
to go along with them magically this
drove the American anime fandom to a
collective nostalgia driven orgasm it's
least sparking a movement to try and
bring back the tsunami block permanently
spearheaded by anime voice acting legend
himself Steve blue now the reason the
tsunami blocks sparked such a bigger
reaction from the fanbase was because of
the huge effect it had on the Western
anime industry during his prime the boom
of anime in the West during the early
2000s had a big deal to do with the
anime that was running on television at
the time coming mostly from the Pokemon
craze
the yellow swim block and of course the
Toonami block there's also this little
thing called the Internet as well that
played a big part but that's a topic for
a different video entirely see while the
Internet may have been responsible for
getting many fans into anime it was most
definitely television that was
responsible for the mass exposure of
anime and for a lot of people tsunami
was their first introduction into that
wild world which until April the first
had long since died so what Adult Swim
did for us doing the revival was
basically setting on nostalgia drives to
over 9,000 and for one night only giving
us our after-school childhood back with
just a brief period allowing us to
relive the memories when we were just a
naive kid gawping at some strange
looking spiky haired men with muscles
like a strangled baby elephant to death
battling in some grand fighting
tournament or in some seizure inducing
kantak robot because the space colonies
must be saved
of course the fanbase are gonna flip out
over it we're slaves to nostalgia I mean
all I have to do to send half you into a
nostalgia driven frenzies do this
oh yeah baby that's right is Dragonball
Z though while I'm both one is moving
and bringing more animated television it
did lead me to ask myself a very simple
question which doesn't just apply to
Toonami but television as a medium in
general the starters side is there still
a point of anime being on television
make no mistake Badwan the Tanami an
Adult Swim block were in their prime it
had a huge effect for anime in the West
and no one is doubting that Smith gets
in the industry but let's be honest here
what this movement is really about is
trying to get back a part of our
childhood that we long for was dead and
there's nothing wrong with that but as
it stands now for the current generation
of anime watches relying primarily on
the Internet
TV has become a redundant medium for us
there's no longer any need for us to
rely on a fixed schedule having to wait
for latest episodes we pick what we
watch when we want to watch it
why would I need to worry about rushing
back home after school to catch the
latest episode of Dragon Ball Z we know
the episodes are already available at my
fingertips or through Funimation's
million three release of the damn thing
why should I have to wait a week to find
out with the latest developments in
Gundam Wing r when I could just marathon
the entire series at once on crunchyroll
and even if they air more recent anime
they would still have to contend with
these same problems back when tsunami
was in his prime TV didn't have to worry
about this sort of competition there was
no DVR no instant fan subtitles no
debate on subs vs. dubs TV was the only
source where this stuff was available
and the internet was still a relatively
new but growing phenomenon in the
present day is the intent that is king
and TV that's been left behind
especially in the community that is
obsessed with having the fastest and
most up-to-date episodes from its
original airtime in Japan TV it seems
just can't keep up there's a reason why
Toonami died in the first place why
Adult Swim is a shadow of his former
self and why just recently rise and
dropped Funimation channels from their
services there just wasn't enough
interest so for us already established
anime watches and for the people crying
up for its revival we don't really need
it and I have to wonder how successful a
revival really would be once the novelty
of nostalgia dies out and people see no
need to be as faithful to a programming
block as they once were when they were
kids so you may be assuming that I think
the tsunami revival or any anime on
television has become a moot point and
to an extent yes I do think so but
there's still one and always will be one
major reason for put
anime on TV the creation of new fans for
me and for many others watching this
video we would have never gotten into
anime if not for it being on television
like many other fans born in the 90s I
first got exposed to animated Pokemon a
wonderful fantasy one in which the earth
is ruled by stuck-up teenage [ __ ]
forcefully domesticated wild animals and
then pitting them against each other in
a fight to a death or issac till one of
them fainted whatever it was awesome and
then Dragonball Z and the rest of the
tsunami shows came along and I was
hooked I needed more of these shows
about big I powered up fighters forever
combatting increasingly powerful
opponents which convinced me to go out
and actively search for more shows like
this resulting in a start to my anime
fandom but that never would have
happened if I never got exposed to it in
the first place on TV without television
the only place new fans would come from
is through word of mouth
whether it be in real life or through
the internet for the anime fandom and
Industry to continue going there always
needs to be an attraction for new fans
because the fact is in a few years when
you finish college or find a job in real
life hits you you won't have as much
time or commitment to be able to plow
through the anime at the pace you do now
that's not a speculation that's not
pessimism that's just life this current
generation of anime fans can't sustain
the industry forever and there will
always be a need for a constant stream
of new fans to keep the fandom afloat so
whether this can be achieved through
word of mouth alone is something that
I'm skeptical over this brings me to
another issue that needs to be addressed
what shows could actually be a hit if
aired in the West to have a chance at
being successful we can't just keep
rearing the same series that have been
around for over a decade I will need
something fresh for the newer generation
but as I mentioned in previous rants
with the decline of the number of anime
garnered for a Western audience and the
slow death of dubbed anime there's less
and less choice of shows I could
possibly have a successful run on TV
Naruto Bleach and one piece are slowly
running its course shows that with
seemingly targeted for American
broadcast such as here oh man panting
stocking or Tiger money haven't even
been dubbed and I doubt slice-of-life or
anything to dangerously Japanese would
be great for drawing people into the
medium you can't show subtitled anime on
mainstream TV because as much as the
community would like to frowned upon the
english-language blemishing their
favorite anime ready for mass broadcast
most people aren't patient enough to get
into a new medium they have no idea
about when it's in a foreign language
especially if they're kids so that's
where we stand now sure more anime on TV
would always have a positive effect on
the industry but whether the fandom
actually needs it whether it can still
be successfully pulled off in this day
and age remains to be seen
whether the anime fandom can continue
growing through the power of the
internet alone or slowly retreat back
into the world of extreme security over
the years it's something that would just
have to wait and see but I guess that's
why I can ask you guys should more anime
come back to TV and if so would it be
successful enough leave a comment or
video response for your chance to get
featured in my next front that's it for
me now though so will your responses to
my previous rant what do you think about
the state of the anime industry some
says it still makes me wonder why we're
stands are not alarmed by this surely we
should be asking why some of the best
anime is available to us surely we
should care in the future favorite
series we know may never see an anime
because we seem completely unwilling to
spend a few pounds it's been said many
times by repeated